- We're showing love to LA this week.
So what do you love about Los Angeles?
What are your favorite parts?
- Oh, well I'm lucky.
So, Zooey was born and raised here,
and so she has shown me a whole side
of LA that I didn't know about.
- Yeah. That's helpful.
- And I love it. Yeah.
But I think probably for us,
the number one thing that we love:
so many escape rooms in LA.
- Oh my God, I love escape rooms.
- Are you into escape rooms?
- I love escape rooms. Here's the thing.
My assistant kicks my ass at them.
She's so good at them.
But I love them.
- So, if we go together, we
want her on our team, not you.
- No! Yes. But, no!
- We love them.
We've done them all over the world.
- We've done them on tour.
We did them all on tour.
Like, yeah, we love them.
They're so fun.
Have you done them?
- An escape room, you mean my audition
with Harvey Weinstein 10 years ago?
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheering)
- [Jonathan] Did you escape?
(Whitney laughs)
- I mean.
- Did you make it?
- I've been an actress in
Hollywood for 10 years.
Every room is an escape room.
- Actually, we heard about the
door, leaving the door open.
So she saw that escape room.
- She's safe, she's safe.
What do you love about LA?
Was that one of your favorite things?
- Yeah, I mean, escape rooms, for me--
Magic Castle is actually--
I just went again
with our nieces and nephews.
They have a brunch too.
So you get a little magic,
you get some lunch, which was always fun.
- [Kelly] That's cool
- Yeah. I mean, there's
so many great things.
Just going around the city of Linden.
I create little date days.
Even during COVID we were
like, in our car for picnics.
And then we would go to like,
an abandoned part of a parking lot
and throw a Frisbee around.
But it's-- going up into the Hills,
wherever we are.
- [Whitney] A Frisbee? You play Frisbee?
- I love-- it's called disc
golf, if you're this good.
Anybody play disc golf?
(Whitney blowing raspberries)
- [Kelly] If you're this good!
- I'm sorry.
- I love it!
- Let me just point something out,
for anyone who doesn't know.
Drew is the most competitive man alive.
- Welcome to your counterpart.
- You're the two people
that ruin game night.
- No! We make it fun!
- Every one of my friends,
at some point, has been yelled at by Drew.
- You're the two that are like,
"Rules are there for a reason.
That's how we have fun.
If you don't follow the rules
we can't enjoy ourselves."
- [Kelly] Okay, that is me. That's me.
- [Whitney] Yes, I know!
- We should play a game night together.
- You will literally kill each other.
- I love it.
- We'll be on the same team.
- I love it. We will destroy you.